after the peripheral there's additional
I'm only going into giving you the names
for these by the way because
occasionally the textbook will do that
and you'll be like what's that talking
about okay I never actually say in a in
I'll use the product rule right you just
think okay DS happened together in what
kind of situation would I say use the
additional you probably guess by the way
I've set it up it's when events are not
simultaneous when they don't happen
together okay some stand-ups a question
my fist probability of getting two heads
so close I ask you what's the
probability of just getting to different
spaces okay that you can see there are
two different ways to get different
faces right your flip once and I've got
I've got our tails here okay so if I get
tails first then I want to a head after
that okay so there's this one
possibility what's the other alternative
if I didn't get tails dressed you put my
heads first then I'd one tails second
okay so now have a look at these
different options here and I'll get a
close-up I've got this as one of the
favorite app comes one of the events I'm
interested in right but then I also have
this okay now these can't happen
simultaneously you can't get a head and
a tail for the first event but at the
same time you get one or you get the
other okay so for normal cell service or
separate things
these that can't possibly happen at the
same time you can't get a hit tail and
and tell him because they're mutually
exclusive right that's when you add the
probabilities so we still know that each
of these is going to be a quarter but in
order to get both of them together right
you go one plus the other that's all
they mean by the addition rule
okay so caught up plus a quarter that
gives you problems easy okay one what
now a company that's simple we know in
geometry a compliment means something
right but in probability and set theory
compliments means something else what
does it mean in this context if I said
for example let's go with this there's
an event what would be the complement of
that event and therefore what would its
probability be so you might remember we
use this kind of we can assign the tills
about number one what is it and then
we'll work out as probability the
comment just means everything else
everything else you know what's the
polity of this not happening okay that's
what the compliment made so if you like
you can taste the opposite event or the
event not happening is a more technical
way to say okay so it's the probability
of this not happening now we know that
the total probability for all of the
outcomes when you add warm-up if you've
got the entire sample space it's equal
to one right the court of the supporters
put up with some quota equals one okay
so therefore if I add up all of the
things that are this it'll be one minus
that right it's like I've got the whole
billionaire oh you just punch that hole
in well in the corner okay take out a
quarter of the running so three quarters
is the probability of not getting two
heads in a row and there's my one two
three quarters okay so the probability
of a compliment right where you can have
any event you like is equal to one minus
the probability of whatever that event
was okay now in this example it's kind
of trivial because there are so few
options right but sometimes the wedding
doesn't tell you it's really obviously a
compliment right and sometimes it's much
easier to work out the opposite example
what if I said what's the probability of
getting the
same side okay now that the language of
it doesn't imply that it's a compliment
of something else but it clearly is
what's it the compliment of getting the
different faces right you're either
getting this or this right I I would
have made obvious if I said the
probability of not getting different
faces but you see this as part of what
makes probability as a topic probability
but you need to see that these two are
the same or if you like say that these
two are opposite it complements okay now
like I said because it's trivial right
you might as well just add them up you
can just go this one and this one it's
the same but sometimes number one you
have already worked this out so you
might as well use it or number two it'll
be much easier to calculate the
complement so do this instead right and
you get a half just like you did before
okay